In these lessons,
you're going to be learning about how
models can be used to summarize data.
You'll learn about some
statistical analyses for
describing incoming data sets.
You'll learn how to compare different
models against one another to see which
one's stronger or
which one's a better fit for some data.
And you'll learn about how models can
then be used to predict future data,
predict future observations.
What we really want you to focus
on here is that model building and
validation component.
We want you to focus on the role of
model building in machine learning, and
how validation let's us compare
different models against one another,
to see which one's a better
fit to use going forward.